AS WE JUMP TO OUR
NEXT GAME, THE 69TH WONDER OF
THE WORLD.
69TH WONDER OF THE WORLD.
A RUSSIAN CREW HAS BEEN ACCUSED
OF FILMING A PORNO MOVIE IN
FRONT OF THE GREAT PYRAMIDS OF
EGYPT.
>> SUCH A DELICATE TOP FOR A
PORN.
>> HARDWICK: YOU NOTICE HOW ONE
PYRAMID'S SMALLER THAN THE OTHER
ONE?
UH...
>> THEY NEED TO-TO FLUFF THAT
PYRAMID.
>> HARDWICK: THEY NEED TO FLUFF
THE PYRAMID.
UH, THE DESERT'S DRY, BUT IT'S A
LITTLE WETTER NOW.
AUTHORITIES...
AUTHORITIES NOTICED, UH, COMMIE
PORN ACTRESS AURITA, SHOWN HERE
IN FRONT OF SOME POINTY STONE
NIPPLES, DISAPPEARING INTO A
RESTRICTED AREA OF THE RUINS
WITH A CAMERA CREW, A PIZZA GUY,
AND SOME SWEATY TEAMSTERS.
FOOTAGE THAT SURFACED LATER
ONLINE MATCHED THE FORBIDDEN
SITE AND PROVED THAT BOOTS WERE
KNOCKED AND UGLIES WERE INDEED
BUMPED.
COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
GIVE ME AS MANY TITLES FOR
ANCIENT EGYPTIAN PORN MOVIES AS
YOU CAN IN 60 SECONDS.
AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
JONATHAN.
>> MR. MARCUS ANTONY AND
CLIT-OPATRA.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
BETH.
>> KING SLUT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
WHIT.
>> ONE IN THE PINK, TWO IN THE
SPHINX.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
BETH.
>> TOMB GIRLS, ONE CUP.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
WHIT.
>> W-WOMB RAIDER.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
BETH.
>> DEM NEFER-TITTIES.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS!
(GRUNTS)
(BELL DINGS)
WHIT.
>> KING [BLEEP]-ON-MY-TUT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
VERY WELL PLAYED. JONATHAN.
>> GOBBLE THE KNOB-ELISK FILMED
AT THE [BLEEP]-SOR.
>> HARDWICK: OH! THAT'S GOOD.
POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
WHIT.
>> THE NILE HIGH CLUB.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
WHIT AGAIN.
>> OH, UM, CAMEL TOE IN THE
DESERT: VOLUME 6.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, EXCELLENT. BETH.
>> PEACE IN THE MIDDLE YEAST.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
WHITNEY.
>> CHLAMYDI-OPATRA.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, JONATHAN.
>> MILFS: MUMMIES I'D LIKE TO
[BLEEP].
(BUZZER SOUNDS)
>> HARDWICK: GODDAMN IT!
IT WAS RIGHT THERE THE WHOLE
TIME!
>> RIGHT THERE.